Hello Freak bitches will tell for people who haven't seen the documentary,
what was going on,
what,
what house?
There was a burglary call at the house.
So we responded as patrol,
right.
And we checked out the place and inside it was two young girls who were sitting
there on the floor and this home,
you know,
with the door knob broken off.
And they said that they were given permission by the owner of the home to spend
the afternoon or day here in her home.
And we'll,
where I had asked her,
well,
where did,
where did the owner happened to be since you,
you know,
you broke the door and all it to get in.
Oh,
she's in prison right now.
I said,
Oh,
and for what?
And she goes,
oh,
I think for drugs.
I said,
Okay Mary,
thank you.
So I turned left hard and there's a box of fucking shoes,
piles,
a box of shoes.
Like if anyone knows anything about the drug business,
they spend a lot of money on their personal shoes because what else are you
gonna spend money on?
You know,
you can't build a new house in the ghetto here that she should wasting your
money,
but you could have a lot of shoes.
So I saw all these boxes of shoes,
nice high heels,
pumps,
all this stuff.
So I said,
okay,
there's a girl in here,
spend a lot of money on shoes.
And the furniture looked pretty good for the location.
So I opened the closet and he has a fucking duffel bag filled with cash.
I pick up actually,
that's really not exactly what happened.
Some anticline guy went in there,
picked up the big,
he looks at me,
I looked at him,
I go,
what are you gonna do a voucher?
This come on and spend all day vouchering them.
I leave it there.
He looks at me,
he looks at me,
he goes,
all right,
he puts it down.
I put my hand in the bag and start stuffing the money in my pockets.
But I had no room.
I didn't have enough room.
I was wearing summer clothes.
I didn't have,
I went to uniform on with the jacket where you can stuff everything.
So anyway,
I said,
this is not gonna work.
It's too much money here.
You know,
you can't,
you can't draw it out of a building with a big field with money and have the
cops see you because they're going to say,
we had the bed go.
Right,
right.
So my enemy was the cops at this point.
So you know,
I found a way to circle a house for an hour and a half and every possible
direction you could add it.
And then chickie finally pulled up with another guy that was retired from the
jail.
They walked in with their dupe badges on and the landlord lets them in and yeah,
up there.
That's it.
Just,
they just left that,
built that apartment right up there.
When he went in,
he come out with a bag.
I've got a minute later,
I pulled him over,
boop,
boop.
Pulled them over.
How are we doing?
Real good.
I go,
what are you gonna do?
That's called Atlantic city.
I go,
great.
I go back to the cell from cell phone.
I go back to the payphone on the corner.
Back then we had the original call form.
You would drive the patrol car up on a curb and just reach out to the fucking,
uh,
at t and t phone booths.
So you'd sit in the patrol car and dial the precincts,
white dial the precinct.
It was a free call by the way.
He didn't have to pay for it.
And uh,
and uh,
they bought my wife,
it needs to be at home right now.
You know,
one of the kids broke a toe or whatever,
you know,
whatever excuse you can come up with.
Okay,
no problem.
Come in and you'd take a Louis Times called last time.
So,
uh,
I told the girl in the car I was working with was an IED plant by the way.
She was,
she was internal affairs plants sitting with me the whole time.
I said,
okay,
I says,
you know,
I gotta go home.
My wife just page,
cause had beepers back then.
My wife just page me the kid's sick or something.
And uh,
so I went back to the precinct signed,
went to Atlantic city and limousine
and so cleaned the money.
The girl who was driving around with you as you were going around for an hour
and a half was a plant.
Yes,
she was internal affairs comp.
I don't believe I ever told anybody that.
Okay.
Let's see here.
National Violence Against Women Survey found that 21.5% of men and 35.4% of
women living with same sex partners experience intimate partner physical.
Yeah,
that's exactly what we're saying.
So that shows that lesbians or more likely to be up their partners.
Then gay men are comparable with 7.1 and 20.4% for men and women respectively
with a history of only opposite sex.
Cohabitation.
That's crazy.
So what that says is that 7.1% of women have experienced domestic violence by
men,
but 20.4% of men have experienced domestic violence by women.
The good thing,
but that says to me is that I am not alone.
Okay,
but that's Massachusetts.
See that right there.
Massachusets is filled with monsters.
Drunk.
Those women,
you'll fucking queen.
They beat your ass.
They're terrible people.
They only check that I ever had.
Take a swing at me.
It was a girl that I dated from Boston.
Really?
She took a swing at me while I was fighting.
I was,
I was in the middle of competition back then like I was,
I was taekwondo.
I was now was kickboxing.
I was fucking crazy like in this chick took a swing at me and I watched it
coming and I was like,
I don't even believe this is happening and I ducked under it and I grabbed a
hold of him.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
Are you hitting me?
He's trying to hit me.
I those are the only time I grow ag.
You fucking queer.
They're monsters.
They drunk.
They eating potatoes just fucking swinging at you.
That's why it's Massachusetts.
I'll bet you look at the rest of the country.
It's probably totally different numbers.
No,
I don't think it's totally ever numbers if you like to do hunts aren't fair.
Chase,
if you like doing it,
why do you,
why do they have such a hard time just saying that's what I'd like to do.
Well,
I spend an enormous amount of time explaining why I like to do what I do.
You know,
why don't,
I would love for more of them to explain to me what they like about it instead
of doing it and acting like they did something different.
Well,
the PR part of it is the network themselves,
right?
The outdoor channel and the sportsmans channel,
they don't allow you to show high fences.
That's part of their byline is right.
I don't know if they say don't show high fences,
they might not want,
this is coming from Ben O'brian.
Yeah,
so they might,
they might,
I can't say that they say don't show it.
Or if they're saying don't do it,
I think they say,
don't show it.
Don't show it.
Because I can't know Jen is on that program.
Right.
He's on those networks.
He's got a huge show on that network.
He hunts in his fucking yard.
I mean,
he's not,
he's not on a big piece of property.
I think he's less than 300 acres or maybe 300 acres.
That's not that much.
And in that 300 acres,
it's all high fence.
He's got African animals,
you've got all kinds of shit in there.
White pig's all in this one area and he hunts high fence almost exclusively.
And when he's hunting on the,
you know it says like spirit wild ranch.
Yeah,
that's his yard.
I mean he's essentially hunting has pets if you really want to look at it that
way.
And He,
his house goes,
sits in his favorite tree.
Stan,
it's probably got a bunch of them all over his property but I don't,
I don't think he's proud of,
I think in and of itself,
I don't feel there's anything wrong with that because my brother raises sheep.
Right.
And when he goes out to get the sheep,
he goes out with a 22 he's got you irrigated pasture,
he runs lambs.
When he goes out to get a lamb,
it gives a lot of the way,
eat some of it for herself.
Shoes the land with the 22 however he doesn't dress it up like he's hunting the
lambs out on his pasture.
Like it's a wild animal is kind of sneak up on.
No,
I mean he did.
He doesn't like put,
he doesn't like put a picture of him in his 22 on in a dead lamb on Facebook.
He's like,
you know what I mean?
He's a hunter.
He's a very avid hunter and never once in his life.
I wish she was here because I'd like to ask them this question.
Never once in his life has he confused the act of farming
organic sheet with the act of hunting wild elk?
Yeah.
It's not confusing to him.
No,
but is it confusing?
Did you have a good hunting year?
He'd be like so far he got an elk.
What does Bo on national forest land,
he got an antelope with his bowl,
BLM land yard,
and he would never be like,
oh,
and I got 10 lamb in my yard.
Yeah.
It's just like,
I already did it.
It's just so weird to me that I feel like we talked about this with dog during
to Doug [inaudible] has to go out now and then and kill a cattle on his farm.
He doesn't like get gussied up in Camo and get like a bunch of pink accents and
like put pink accents all over his gun and go out
and go out and like shoot the cows on his property.
Right.
It'd be like,
no,
I wouldn't shut my cow.
Right.
He wouldn't make a TV show where he's like acting like he's hunting his cows,
but his fence is only,
you know,
20 yards.
Whereas Ted Nugent's fences,
300 acres.
Yeah.
I can't really speak to it cause I just,
I'd had to just go see it.
Okay.